okay I've got some great books to
recommend to you today as always david
pakman.com slash recommendations for all
of my recommendations if you use the
links there to buy these books on amazon
we get a slice of every transaction
david pakman.com slash recommendations
today I have two fiction one non-fiction
let me start with the latest book by
john lecarre a as many of you know john
lecarre a one of my favorite authors I
think I've read all but one of his books
20 or so john lecarre a is extremely
prolific he has been putting out a good
book basically every few years since the
early 60s I think it was the early or
mid sixties when spy who came in from
the cold came out that might have been
like 68 that was his third book so I
think his first one must have been 62 63
somewhere in there extremely prolific
the author of such books as the constant
gardener spy who came in from the cold
the Tinker Tailor trilogy a most wanted
man is a very good one the tailor of
Panama anyway the last few books by John
Locke are a have been by normal
standards very good but not his best
work the latest one called agent running
in the field which published just a
month or two ago I would argue is his
best book of the last I think I would
say ten years or even longer excellent
excellent book it's sort of the merging
of two two different stories one of a
sort of retiring soon to retire spy who
is brought back home to have sort of a
relatively mundane not particularly well
respected position and the overlap
between that and a friend that this
individual makes went back in London
that I'll tell you that and nothing else
excellent book very quick read I highly
recommend it number two the latest book
by Blake Crouch Blake Crouch has been a
guest on this program Blake Crouch wrote
dark-matter he authored good behavior
which has been turned into a TV show
somewhere I think although I've not seen
it he authored way
Pines I believe that's a trilogy I think
that's been turned into a series his
latest book is recursion it is a sci-fi
book it is not it is sort of a time
travel book but not in the traditional
sense it's a time travel book the likes
of which I've never read before and I'll
just give you this little grain if this
seems interesting then definitely pick
this one up in most time-travel stories
if I travel back to my year through the
year I was five years old 1989 I would
be my current age but I would be living
in 1989 and I continue aging
consecutively in this book the concept
is I travel back to 1989 with all of the
knowledge and experience that I
currently have but I go back to being
five years old and I'm basically
reliving years of my life that's the
concept very different than most time
travel books recursion by blake crouch
get this one if you're into sci-fi
very very good sentient Blake a note
about it and maybe we'll have them back
on the program really great stuff okay
those are two fiction recommendations
and I have just one non-fiction
recommendation for you this is a thick
one so I've been getting through fewer
books because I've been reading some
some big boys this is principals by Ray
Dalio Ray Dalio is I believe in his
early 70s 70s now he is one of the most
successful investors a lot of people
know about Warren Buffett fewer people
in sort of popular culture know about
Ray Dalio maybe it's Dalio not sure he
pronounces it but this book is it's not
an investment book it's not a business
book it's not an autobiography it's sort
of all of these things and more and it
is very interesting from the point of
view of growing an organization if
you're interested in that it's
interesting from the point of view of
how one matures and changes their
perspective on their work as they grow
and age which I found super interesting
and it is not super dense I mean it's
for the number of pages that it is which
I think is like nearly 600 yes nearly
600 pages it's a relatively quick read
and if you're into this type of book or
even if you're
I would recommend that you try it check
out david pakman.com slash
recommendations for all of these and
more remember if you get any of these
using the links at david pakman.com
slash recommendations we get a little
slice of your transaction and that is of
course very much appreciated